i want to thank my co-stars
uh leo
margot robbie margot robbie's feet
margaret crawley's feet dakota fanning's
feet
seriously quentin has separated more
women from their shoes than the tsa
[Applause]
i've never been to australia you haven't
i've never been i know so many people
from australia and i wanted to talk to
you because you're amazing and i'm so
excited for you it's incredible that
you've gotten as far as you have with
your obvious physical disadvantages
unbelievable peyton manning is here
[Music]
peyton you look like if a kid with down
syndrome wished he was big
[Applause]
and all the good things that jerry lewis
does people always make fun of him but
what about the good things that he does
what about the fact that just last labor
day a six-year-old kid
got up out of his wheelchair and walked
for the very first time
to turn off the jerry lewis telethon
one of my favorite uh actors steve
carell yeah it's a pleasure to meet you
you know i hear the camera adds 10
pounds looks like you've eaten five
cameras
i'm working on my body and i just don't
like i have chocolate i'm lying yeah see
yeah
and then it turns you on no it doesn't
you just said you did no i didn't mean
it in that way okay
[ __ ]
all right
yes kennedy you know kennedy is i know
every single one they all do the same
move they drop down and do the splits
that's what i think when i'm watching
your shows too you know all the same
stuff but
put it in our face oh
you had one job
in my head you were so much better with
balls
[Applause]
you got melania a huge 12 carat diamond
engagement ring you should not have
gotten her a diamond now she knows what
hard is supposed to feel like
no but greg corralo i'm just joking him
he has the grace of a swan the wisdom
and owl and the eye of an eagle ladies
and gentlemen this man is for the birds
how about a hand for your host larry
king everybody thanks bob
you always say nice things about me
we've done a few of these together and
you're always a little less funny each
time
this isn't a roast but if it was a roast
ladies and i would say larry king is to
comedy what martin luther king is to
comedy
of course my idol milton berle god bless
you milton what a night for you you've
been such a great star over the years
and now we're going to put you in a home
no no no no
pam just for the record i think it's
kind of hypocritical that you care so
much about animal rights since you've
been torturing your own beaver for years
so rebel are you a big fan of game of
thrones
i have to admit i'd never seen game of
thrones
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so before i say anything uh i
promised my friend iris that y'all got a
lot of friends i'm sorry
where are your friends
sorry friends
may be a term you don't know
i like that i like that she clipped your
wings falcon
i don't know the term friends i know the
term family
when stuff
when stuff get tight when stuff get
tight let me see where your friend at
but grow a little bit you will get there
count a question for you
you have won exactly one fight since
barack obama was president
[Applause]
[Applause]
to a place where time doesn't exist six
months ago
thank you
it's lucky you're beautiful because
there's nothing up here what that's mean
did you just tell me dumb
you went straight to dumb like woman i
was like oh you're wearing my grandma's
sweater and then you're like you're dumb
rob riggle claims he used to be a marine
but he also claims he's now a comedian
so i don't know what to believe
rob served in afghanistan before
becoming a stand-up comic then the real
bombing began
i gotta ask you a question a hat it's
one thing to wear the hat backwards do
you have an afro under that or something
it looks uh it looks very very high
i'll tell you what they're saying
that hey that's none of your damn
business okay whatever's going on up
under my hat is none of your business
the only information that you need to
know is that i don't have a mushroom on
the top of my head like you that's right
stephen a
i have a cut from this year all right
you don't really act you don't sing you
don't dance you don't have any
forgive me any talent but we're still
entertaining people katie seagal you're
an incredible actress you worked on
married with children the show that
changed comedy sons of anarchy the show
that took drama to a whole new level and
eight simple rules the show that killed
john ritter
dinero is sitting there god bless you
bob he's got the beard on
to know him is a treat he's one of the
great actors of our time you ask him
uh
[Music]
got to see james corden as a fat [ __ ]
he was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that um
and the reviews are shocking i saw one
that said this is the worst thing to
happen to cats since dogs right
but dame judy dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she
i can't do this next joke
she loves nothing better than plonking
herself down on the carpet lifting her
leg and licking her
furball verbal
she's old school um
it's the last time who cares
testimony during the final week provided
some spell-binding moments
in a brilliant move during closing
arguments
simpson attorney johnny cochran put on
the knit cap prosecutors say o.j war the
night he committed the murders although
o.j may have hurt his case when he
suddenly blurted out hey hey easy with
that that's my lucky stabbing hat
and victory back you shouldn't have come
you made a fool of yourself i'm a friend
and bubba
with a few almonds on your face we got
candy
you would think you were the only cover
girl in town do you know i'm a cover
girl i'm
surprised
but probably yes
if you dare say who's that other man on
the cover
you look fabulous in one it was just
don't start with me
you're so jealous i asked you to come on
tonight and look glamorous look what you
showed up at i
like to think am understated is a lot
classier than all the the stuff hanging
out all of the really just ridiculous
little tassels can you get them all
going in opposite directions
with a major
fan you look wonderful now you can see
yourself seriously sir because you're on
a cover
not a major publication but nonetheless
not a major publication
dogs i tell you that's a very major
publication for your career though
that's a good story now
it's funny because people wanted me
topless but i said no and weren't you
like that's so hard to tell
ah i bet you'd be funny on a date if you
ever have one